Well,
there they are,
Shira Mr Creeps in his partner,
Mr Kroll.
I've been asked to make a video on plot
twists and it's just about the beginning
of this channel,
but I was always hesitant to do it
because I didn't want to spoil a bunch
of major plot twists.
I stood by this principle until I came
across an interesting study conducted by
UC San Diego.
Researchers had one group of
participants read several famous books
after the researchers spoiled their
endings while another group read the
books.
Normally after reading each group noted
how much they liked each book.
Based on the results,
it turns out that if the ending is
spoiled to you before you read a book,
you actually end up liking the book
more.
Not only do I think this study perfectly
explains what makes a plot twist great.
I also like it because it helps me
justify spoiling some movies.
I'll have to spoil.
Now you see me and primal fear with the
prestige having only very minor
spoilers.
If you haven't seen one,
consider what the study says and use
this video as an opportunity to recreate
the experiment.
So let's get spoiling.
We are going to follow those dirty,
find that data.
The common definition of a plot twist is
a totally unexpected outcome to a story,
and now you see me.
Dylan roads is an FBI agent trying to
track down the four horsemen,
but in a shocking twist,
it turns out he was the fifth horseman
all along.
While I do think the rest of the movie
is pretty fun,
there's one key reason that this plot
twists doesn't really work.
Now you and our shipping
shoddily a bomb goes off.
I'm the FBI,
got past him not once,
not twice,
but consistently,
almost as if they were on the in.
A lot of the audience had seen five or
10 seconds or shock.
Even though the original shows are
pretty simple and predictable,
scooby doo actually adheres to an
important principle of good plot twists.
The final payoff always follows the
established logic.
At the beginning of each episode,
they were trying to scare all the years
off the island.
Then no one would spend the night and
they would keep control of a fortune.
We get just enough information in the
beginning so that when the twist does
happen,
it's satisfying.
Since there was always that looming
feeling that you know who did it,
creeps and crawls,
they sure picked the right lawyers for
this job.
Can you see me?
Twist has this element missing.
It follows very little established
logic.
The complete rewriting of the character
from a clumsy FBI agent to accounting
genius means there was really no way to
see this plot twists coming and that's
why it's not very satisfying and relies
too heavily on shock.
The Prestige is the perfect balance
between the shock value of the.
Now you see me twists and the
predictable but logical twists of Scooby
Doo.
Twenty minutes into the movie,
we've technically been told enough to
predict the plot twist,
but Christopher Nolan leaves just enough
information out to make the ending.
An amazing shock that still follows
established logic.
You do the sheen over again,
but we tell the audience a bomb
underneath this table is going to five
limit.
You're looking for the secret,
but you won't volunteer because you're
coke's not really.
Plot twist is the one that can create
the biggest surprise without ruining the
established logic because at the end of
the day,
the twisted,
now you see me,
isn't actually that satisfying.
It's a complete rewrite of his character
for a cheap surprise.
It's not particularly interesting to
change 100 percent of a character's
personality that has been built up
throughout the whole movie,
so how do you do this in a surprising
but also entertaining way and primal
fear.
The plot twist is similar,
but with one key difference in the movie
and alter boy is accused of murdering
and archbishop and the lawyer gets him
off not guilty by reason of insanity,
because the boy test positive for
multiple personality disorder.
The film ends with the final scene
before the altar boy is moved to a
psychiatric hospital.
Here he reveals,
he faked it the whole time.
To get a short sentence,
there never was an aaron counselor.
It may seem like pure shock,
but this ending is actually carefully
woven into the logic of the story
throughout the movie.
We're not sure which personality he is
or what he's about to change his
identity,
so we've always had this feeling that he
wasn't who he says he was,
but the shock is still fantastic because
we go from being on his side to him,
tricking everybody in the story,
including us and switching to an
antagonist.
At the very end.
We got the information,
but it's still a surprise and it's what
separates the good plot twists from the
bad ones
in order to
provide the audience with a certain
amount that had for me.
Come on,
Marty.
I thought you had it figured out.
Yeah,
and leave the rest of it to their own
imagining,
but to tell you the truth,
I'm glad you figured it.
I have been dying to tell you,
give them just enough to see it coming,
but not enough to expect it.
I think the best way to test a good plot
twist is if the movie is re watchable
because once you know the twist ending,
if the ending is a good one,
then it's just as fun.
If not more fun to go back and see where
they hint at that twist ending.
Totally.
I think that's why the studies shows how
spoiling a book before reading it makes
it more enjoyable.
This expense of the ending makes the
path getting there that much more
exciting and maybe that's why lots of
stories spoiled the ending at the very
beginning
and me,
I'm the damn
for the charter because as much as it's
about the plot twists,
it's about how you get there,
so feel free to watch something even if
you know how it ends,
because who knows?
Maybe you'll like it even more.
They bring the dog and come in the
waiting in.
Thanks for watching.